welcome to
my presentation on an ecosystem for the
digital app
key aspects and possibilities my name is
freyk
farrocio i'm an application engineer and
i'm supporting customers
in the area of openhab cds the
integration to limb systems and
reporting
the subtopic for today will be
integrating opelapcds into your
environment in other words into your
entire
laboratory automation
topics for this seminar are quite simple
we have a short powerpoint presentation
an introduction
we're going to integrate overlap cds
with
limbs and we have a middle layer for
that called sample scheduler
we explain to you how it works and we
even show it live to you
and at the end of the live demo we have
a short wrap-up of a few bullet points
which repeats what we have told before
so the short introduction
now we talk about the role of the cds in
the laboratory and quite
often we think that when you are in the
lab and running your samples
you can get the impression that
everything revolves around the lap
and in particular around the
chromatography data handling system
as the dockery data handling system can
generate a lot of
results that need to be put back into
the systems
however the laboratory
and the chromatography data hunting
system is just another
data provider for production systems
like
sap or like a lymph system or any other
particular production system out there
so in the bigger picture from an i.t
perspective and from your operation
perspective this
chromatoxy data handling system your cds
it's just another
granule in a large heap of scent
it is an important granule though
because we're providing a lot of
information
and on based on that information
production will be
altered will be steered by and also
particular results and batches and
products and products
will be released based on the results we
provide
the other thing is is just in time data
providing
now but the pressure on us today
is to provide more and faster results
and yet with ever less people in the
laboratory
um work is getting more and more and we
have less and less so
operators today coming from the
production floor
are now performing analytical tests on
their own
and expected to do that with less
supervision
so they're on their own at night and
there's nobody present
and in order to achieve such
a workflow yeah solid investments need
to be
made to cater these new workflows and
new demands
so the less people you have the more you
have to invest
in automation and automated workflows
less errors in transcription another
source
of wrong decisions made manual transfer
and double checking of results is not
only
time consuming but also a source of
errors what is actually desired
is that at the end of the analysis an
automated transfer
after electronically checking the
results is done
so we would like to have an electronic
review of the data
and then an electronic transfer of the
results
everything in specifications oh
the other thing is sample planning
knowing upfront
which work is in the pipeline for you in
other words which samples will be taken
in the field
so and knowing which samples are coming
it's day and night
yeah and you also want to know which
samples are canceled so running ad hoc
samples and managing priorities
upfront simply make life easier and
prevents
aggravation as people are not surprised
and disrupted in the daily work now
there's nothing more
irritating that you have dropped
everything you're working on at that
very moment
and you have to pick up sample because
somebody is banging at the door
and at the end cost saving so it's work
smarter with less people
but what you also want is less work load
on employees
and doing more with less is often
hurting companies today
lean organization and with the
increasing production
and the leaner organization in other
words less people on the work floor
the pressure increases on those
individuals
and they have to work longer and might
will be
home later at the evening that's not
good it's also a cost
people making extra hours to achieve
what they normally
do and by
choosing the right automation steps
reduction over time and work loan can be
achieved
next slide
the integration of overlap cds and
sample scheduler so what we're going to
show you here is the
ability to interface the overlap cds
with the lymph system by means of a
middle layer
it's called the sample scheduler and the
sample scheduler is kind
kind of a roundabout where
samples come in and results are coming
out
so let's look at what we are facing here
so if we are looking at the
traditional workflow in the lab
is that we have a laboratory information
management system
irrespective of which one and it could
be your home stricken one
it could be a commercial one it could be
your uh
your sap that is having the sample
information the sample information is
sent to the
field to collect the samples and the
samples then
coming into the board three where users
have to manually transcribe those
results into the cds
so this is transcription error
source number one we have people working
on sequences and single samples and
sending it to the individual instruments
by hand the instrument generator results
there are reviewed and then the users
are entering those results manually into
back
into limbs and this is not a source of
errors here the manual
entry of results back into limbs and
maybe time consuming because
those results might need to be reviewed
by a
second user or a second reviewer so this
entire operation here is this
circle is quite classy
i see it a lot and we still see it a lot
but it's also time consuming and error
prone
how can we simplify by using sample
scheduler
and that's the big question and we
depict in the next
slide so what we have
is still the same lymph system or your
sap system and the same samples are
still generated
but instead of having reports or pieces
of paper
printed out and sent to the laboratory
the lims
either generates a task for the sample
scheduler in xml format
or the sample schedule on its own pulls
the limbs
from the system and those test requests
are
coming into the scheduler itself
where they're automatically dispatched
to the various instruments
what is still required of course is that
users are putting the samples into the
tray
and when those samples are into the
instrument trace
with a simple mouse click the user
activates
and schedules the the run so that the
instrument
actually works with the runs
results are generated automatically and
then
the results are automatically
transferred back to limbs
either directly or
with an electronic review step
in both cases there is no manual entry
anymore
so this entire workflow is now
simplified
in tech steps that are automated
processes
and the only way what we see here is the
manual
results entry is gone it's automatically
either being reviewed or not and the
manual work still is the sample prep and
putting the samples into the instruments
now how does that look like on a real
screen
and we see this little screen here there
you go to enlarge this a little bit
uh this is the classic user interface
there's also a web
based user interface what we see here is
the different samples that are running
on different instruments in different
laboratories
and what their status is one is
submitted the other one is running this
one is still on its way
we have here an error system and on
sample 5 it might be that something is
wrong with the dtc
the nice thing is though that you can
now assign this job
to another gc that might run the same
method so you would have a very nice
overview from your desk
somewhere sitting in the office of what
is going on
in the laboratory
now how does it work in this case so
let me explain to you this in two simple
screen
shots here
we have a lymph system and anything in
orange is limbs activity
anything in blue is sample schedule
activity and everything in gray
is the opelap cds so the lims
generates xml files as you can see here
on the top
xml and the xml files is drop into an
inbox
for the scheduler the scheduler has a
limbs agent running it picks up
the the tasks sent out by the lymphs
put it in the database and the cds the
chromatory overlap agent picks the task
up
and assigns that to the right
instruments
in the limbs folder we export the
results
and the limbs agent picks up the results
and put it back into limbs so this is
again
a closed loop system so this is on xml
files and with xml files
we cater many many different uh mr lim
systems
sap systems or whatsoever
but this is still file based and there
are plenty of
pharma companies out there that say we
do not like
at all files that are being sent around
so what we'd like to see is that we
would
and transparent interface
between the sample scheduler and the
limbs database and this is what we do
here
anything here in bright orange is still
limbs
blue is still the scheduler and gray is
still
the chromatography data handling system
and what we have here is that we are
picking up the uh
are we picking up the work from the sql
system
directly by using uh
sql statements in the agent so the limps
provides intermediate tables in the
database
and the sample scheduler agent is
picking this up using sql statements
and then the same process applies
the scheduler puts it on the agent the
agent puts it on the instrument
and at the end the results are sent back
into
the lims database so that is again
another closed loop
activity
so what is going to be next the next
thing is a demo how does this look
in real life so i'm going to close this
powerpoint presentation
and then uh we will look at the software
so
so you have now a nice view of my
pc and what i have provided for you here
today
is a client server system so i have here
an ecm server
the server is both lim server
as well as it is the opelap server as
well as
the sample scheduler server so three
jobs
in one system and then i have an opelap
client which then is the
sample scheduler client but it's also
running the instruments
and you get providing me the user
interface
so client server in this case let me
make this full screen so we can
enjoy the entire
resolution and the first thing i need to
do is
i need to log on to the system
now what do we see on my screen
we see here and let us focus first here
the control panel
of opelap cds2 where i have my
instruments
i might have different laboratories and
in the different laboratories i might
have different
instruments being placed here
we're going to use the gcs from the qc
lab and we're going to use
virtual machine today we can even
probably use also the dha
laboratory if we have plenty of time to
do that
and we also have here
the sample scheduler is a classic user
interface what we call fet
client and it allows us to see which
samples are being locked from the limbs
onto the sample scheduler it's still
empty because we're going to mimic
at work how that how that goes into the
normal workflow
and on the other end we have also the
web browser
and the web browser shows me my
instruments and we're logged on here
on that particular web browser as i
believe if i'm not mistaken here as john
wayne
which is an operator and also here we
have
john way in that case
right so i um i started my
presentation and explanation how we can
work between sample scheduler
and and a limb system is that we can
have xml
files being provided by the limbs
to the sample scheduler to put into the
system
and i'm going to mimic with my mouse
how a limbs works so i have here
a bunch of xml files so i'm going to
select them all
and the limps create generates those xml
files they create
xml files and drops them into an inbox
of the sample scheduler so i'm copying
the work over into my limit commands
and it's being there and it's being
absorbed by the system
it's quicker gone than you think
yeah and i can even do that also for my
dha
and i dropped it in my limbs commands
and copying it over here so i have a
number of activities
placed into my limbs command and what we
can see here already on my web browser
is that i have 13 pending samples
to be done as i've already said before
is that i also use can use
my sql statements to pull samples from
the database
and for that i need to feed my lymph
system
with samples and i can do this
automatically here with a script
that allows me to fill my
limps database with samples that need to
be analyzed today
so i'm quickly adding samples to my
leaves database and
that lymph database will be pulled by
the sample scheduler automatically
so let me make this smaller for you
because we don't have any use for that
anymore
we can already see that we have 14
samples
pending in the system and by just giving
a simple click
as everything is interactive
i can see which has been all scheduled
for me i can add
manually samples to it i can search i
can select them all for instance
and then i can assign them to myself
as john wayne then the user
will be here as john wayne depicted
i can delete if i don't want them we see
them the status is waiting
i can also start them what we can see
here also
sneaky in the background a sequence has
been added
which is done by using the sql statement
which is actually polling the database
and auto assigning it to me and we have
here blank
system suitability injections
calibrations
and particular samples being added to it
so both activity has been working the
xml
has been working and the sql has been
working and i can just uh
select here my uh my samples
my my entire sequence and i can just
start my sequence directly from here and
schedule it
kovit forces us to work at home and when
you have a puppy you will have a lot of
noise
here in the sample scheduler we can have
an overview of what is going on we have
our dha
we have our gc and we have our sample
scheduler
and